ANDREA RUSSELL: I'll be
joined in a little bit
by a few customers,
and we're going
to talk today about how you
can build top notch marketing
technology at scale
with Google Cloud.
But, before we get
into the content,
I'd love to get a sense
of who's in the room.
So raise your hand if
you're a developer.
OK, there are a few of us.
Raise your hand if you're in
sales or in another business
role.
OK, a little fewer.
Raise your hand if you work at
an advertising or a marketing
technology company.
If you're already in this space.
Awesome.
Great.
So it's nice to have
all of you in the room.
And before we dive
into the content,
I want to start by level
setting a little bit.
Over the past 10 years, there's
been an explosion of new ad
tech and martech companies.
chiefmartec.com hosts
an annual conference
where they talk
about the industry
and they document the
number of companies in it.
In 2016 when they
published this infographic,
there are about 3,500 companies.
They just released the newest
infographic a few days ago
with well over 7,000 companies.
So the growth of
technology in this space
has been supported
by CMOs themselves
who are signaling
with their wallets.
A 2018 Gartner CMO study
found that CMOs are now
spending more on technology
than IT departments.
And about a third
of marketing budgets
are now spent completely
on technology.
But even as the
industry grows, we're
starting to see much more
mergers and acquisitions.
The industry is both
growing and consolidating.
And the reality is, even
as the industry sustains
enormous growth, new
challenges are emerging.
For the majority
of my career, I was
working in the
advertising technology
space at a few different
companies before Google.
And I've had the
opportunities to speak
to CMOs at large
brands and advertisers,
as well as CTOs and CEOs at
marketing technology companies.
For the past two years, I've
been focused on our Cloud
Marketing initiative,
helping companies migrate
and re-platform to Google Cloud.
And what I've been hearing
from these businesses,
these companies, is
that the way marketers
do business is changing.
And I want to highlight
two challenges, which
are driving this shift.
The first challenge
is that marketers
are shifting from
traditional advertising
to a focus on a
customer experience.
The ask has now become,
how do you create
a compelling, personalized
experience, which
drives revenue, while
also adhering to security
and privacy
Regulations marketers
and CMOs see where
the ball is going.
And according to a 2017 Gartner
survey, 81% of marketers
expect to be competing
mostly or completely
on the basis of customer
experience in two years time.
And in two years
time, that's now.
So enterprises need to be
more thoughtful about how
they're managing customer data.
This means new
processes, new methods,
new ways of tackling
these challenges.
And in this new world
of customer experience,
it's really high stakes.
Because the risk is that
if you get this wrong,
you degrade user trust.
Whether your user is a publisher
or a user at the other end
of a computer screen.
The second challenge
in this ecosystem
is that differentiation
is becoming
increasingly difficult. Why?
This is actually caused by what
I would say two main reasons.
The first is just the crowded
nature of the ecosystem.
There are more and
more companies,
we saw in that first
slide the infographic,
competing and specializing
in the same space.
As competition and
scale increases,
margins start to get
compressed and companies start
to have to do more with less.
At the same time, the speed
of innovation is increasing.
As the world and technology
becomes more efficient,
advertising becomes more
efficient, and more and more
competitors migrate
to the cloud.
They become more agile,
better able to respond
to business needs.
According to a 2013
study by Seismic,
marketers actually
show a clear preference
for working with fewer
vendors in this space, which
means it's more important
than ever to stand out.
And you need a Cloud platform
that can help you do that.
So responding to this
changing ecosystem
requires a change in
mindset and a different way
of thinking about how you
build your technology.
Companies are just like humans.
Companies are made up of humans.
We like to do things
that are comfortable.
Things that are easy.
And most of the time that means
maintaining the status quo.
Doing things the same way
you did it previously.
But maintaining the status quo
isn't a recipe for success.
And taking a new
approach often requires
making real change that
will enable you to actually
grow and differentiate
your business.
Google Cloud is a
technology that's
been built to help
businesses transform.
And it's actually just
an external version
of the technology
and capabilities
that Google has
built over the years
to support both our advertising
and our consumer-facing
products.
You can think of Google Cloud
like the invisible support
beams that helped to make all
the cool things that Google
does possible.
It's a safe, reliable, and
scalable place for companies
to build and innovate.
Whether you're moving an
entire marketing platform,
marketing technology
business, or just
migrating one small data
and analytics workload.
It's also a platform that has
close ties to our advertising
business.
And this has huge benefits
for companies in the marketing
technology space because
you can decide how
you want to partner with us.
Whether that's as
an integration layer
or whether that's with a
joint go to market plan.
In fact, we've already worked
with a number of companies
in this space and we've
seen great success.
Mixpanel is actually a San
Francisco-based analytics
company.
They track user interactions
over web and app
and they're focused on
driving and measuring
user engagement and retention.
They are an analytics
company and they
had hugely demanding workloads.
Their average customer query was
scanning about 50,000 events.
And some of their queries
could reach as much as 10
billion events.
The problem is, as they scaled,
they ran into huge issues
with their bare metal servers.
They weren't able to reach
the same performance.
They were running into server
downtime and system failures.
So they made the decision
to migrate to Google Cloud
and they were able to
achieve higher performance
and achieve the scale that
they needed to support
their enterprise customers.
They wanted to
maintain a median query
time of one second
for each query
in order to maintain
that real time analytics.
And I think the interesting
part about this story,
it's not on this slide,
but they actually
were able to reclaim 30%
to 50% of engineering time
for engineering product
development, which is huge
when you're thinking about ways
that you can innovate and grow
your business.
Reclaiming 50% of
engineering time is amazing.
So companies like
Mixpanel see huge benefits
from partnering
with Google in ways
like achieving global scale
while reducing infrastructure
costs.
They're able to analyze
valuable data and drive growth.
And also future-proof their
business with our smart,
secure, and open platform.
And I want to dive into
a few of these topics.
So I want to speak a little
bit about our purpose-built
infrastructure.
Google Cloud has the most
extensive cloud network
with the farthest reach.
We have over 100
points of presence.
If you've been to our keynote
or been to any other sessions,
I'm sure you've heard
a lot about this.
This means that we have higher
availability, lower latency,
and better security.
And especially when
you're thinking
about reaching the right
user at the right time
with the right message, it's
key to maintain that scale,
while being secure
at the same time.
And our network can
definitely help you do that.
Aside from our
network products, we
have an entire suite
of data products
that are tailor-made for
whatever challenges you face.
Whether that's needing
to query petabytes
of data or ingested
millions of rows per second.
The cool thing here is
that, as a Cloud customer,
you have direct access
to the software systems
that we've built for
our ads business.
And many of these products were
BigQuery, Dataproc, Spanner,
Pub/Sub, Bigtable,
all can manage
the scale of our ads products.
And you can use them
to the open standards
with proprietary performance.
These products also
make it easy for you
to share your data with
your customers, which
is really important with
your customer experience
head on if you're thinking about
helping your customers get all
their data in the same place.
I want to a dive a
bit into Bigtable.
Raise your hand if you're
familiar with Bigtable?
OK, good.
So if you're not
familiar, Bigtable
is a fast, globally distributed,
wide column, NoSQL database.
And if all of that sounds like
gibberish to you, that's fine.
Basically this means that
Bigtable is a super low latency
database that serves
you the information
exactly when you
need it globally.
And so when you were thinking
about ad tech companies,
martech companies who we need
to serve up in real time,
Bigtable is a product that's
super, super helpful for that.
And it's also fully managed.
This means your
engineers can focus
on building new features,
new tools, new products,
rather than maintaining a
database, like BigQuery.
Lastly, Bigtable
provides easy integration
with open source big data tools.
So it's completely compatible
with existing Apache HBase
setups and other Apache
services, like Spark and Storm.
Keeping on that theme, the
entire Google Cloud Platform
is built to support your
business and the way
that you work, whatever
your Cloud capabilities are
or wherever you are
on your journey.
So over the past
10 years, Google
has been super intentional
in our support of open source
projects, from early
work in containers,
to Linux, to GitHub, to Python.
So this means when you
choose Google Cloud,
you're not locked in.
And if you saw our
keynote this morning,
you heard a lot about that with
some of our new announcements.
But basically, we
want to help you
do what you want to do and use
our products in the ways that
supports your business best.
So you can use GKE you on
prem to create a single pane
view for managing
all your clusters,
regardless of where they are.
And this leaves
you free to migrate
what makes sense for
you, but also gives you
flexibility and control.
So, to summarize, Google Cloud
is built from the bottom up
to help you build smarter
and innovate faster.
Whether that's providing a
unique customer experience
or analyzing data to
help your customers
receive richer insights.
It's a powerful
platform that's built
to help you build a better
version of your business.
And I want to bring
up a few customers
to share about how they're
using Google Cloud, why
they choose Google Cloud, and
what they're building next.
So I'd love to invite up
Paul Ryan, the CTO of OpenX.
Put your hands together.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL RYAN: Thank you.
Hello.
I'm Paul.
So what is OpenX?
OpenX is an ad exchange.
What does that mean?
That means we get around
2.5 trillion requests
for ads a month, which
translate into 4.5
trillion specific events
per day that we track.
We work with publishers,
the supply side,
and help them fill
their inventory slots.
We reach out to the
demand side, a couple
of hundred folks that are
proxies for advertisers.
And so it's a big exchange.
High volume
transaction processing.
Lots of things going on.
Lots of moving parts.
OpenX is 100% on prem right now.
And we're migrating into GCP.
As we speak, we're
testing in Singapore
for what we call our delivery
sites, our front end exchange
site, which actually
runs the auction.
So why would a
company this large
with such demanding online
transaction processing
requirements move to the cloud?
Isn't the cloud like
way more expensive,
and it's not going to work.
And how is it going to scale
to the workloads that you need?
So we had all these
questions pretty much
at the beginning of 2018.
And so we went on a journey
to figure out specifically
how the public
cloud might help us,
potentially in a hybrid mode.
With a little bit
of investigation
we said, well, what the
hell, why go hybrid?
Why don't we see what it
looks like if we're fully
in the public cloud?
And so I'm going to talk a
little bit about that journey
and give you a little bit
more background on OpenX
and why we decided to use GCP.
So on the publisher side,
we work with basically
all the largest
publishers in the world.
People that really want to
fulfill their ad requirements
and actually generate revenue.
So, obviously, it is a
very demanding client set.
And there are some
unique challenges
working with both the
publishers and the demand
side of the ad tech ecosystem.
And, frankly, if you look at
the LUMAscape or the chart
that we just saw, there's
thousands of players.
But, fundamentally,
when a user is on an app
or on a publisher's site,
potentially, they're
working through a
JavaScript container
to call out to lots
of different exchanges
that each call out to a lot
of different demand side
platforms, which
are representing
brands for advertising.
So this diagram tells you
kind of the problem set.
There's a tremendous amount
of networking going on.
of requests going out.
And then you've got
to process them, save
all the requests and the
responses, to figure out, oh,
who won the auction?
Did you get an impression?
And who do you pay the money to?
And who do you bill?
So that's kind of the ecosystem.
There's tons of tech.
There's lots of different
companies involved.
And actually, EB is
Exchange Bidding.
That's Google.
And so Google is
heavily involved
in the programmatic ecosystem.
So what's really needed to win
in programmatic is you have
to have a global footprint.
Even 100% on prem, we have
five data centers worldwide.
Because you have to be close
to the supply side, the client,
the consumer, the
person using the app.
That latency is very important.
But you also have to be
close to the demand side
because you're requesting
bids from them.
And so you kind of
have to place things
in the middle around
the world in order
to get the best performance.
You want the lowest
latency, as I said,
to the endpoints and
consumers that you're using.
And frankly, it's
got to be flexible.
I mean, if our average
CPU utilization on prem
is like 20%, that's all
you need to know, right?
It's a 5x trough
to peak universe.
And gosh, isn't
that auto scaling?
Can't you do
something about that?
And it's really real-time
and I call web scale.
So at any given moment, we could
be up to 2 million requests
per second.
And as I said, more
than $4 trillion events.
So this is a pretty
demanding set of workloads.
So how do you select a
public cloud provider?
There's only three
easy steps, right?
Everything's three easy steps.
So you identify the providers
that have a worldwide footprint
and can operate at that scale.
And realistically, there's
probably three or two
and a half.
Maybe two and three quarters.
So you identify
the usual suspects
that you would see in
the Gartner quadrant
up to the right.
Then you actually have
to do a proof of concept.
Because your mileage will vary.
Depending on the
critical components
of your infrastructure, they're
going to behave differently.
Regardless of whether you're
using Kubernetes on parameter
100% containerized, it's going
to be a little bit different.
The bang for the buck in
instances will be different.
The networking profile
will be different.
So you've got to POC some stuff.
And then you model it.
You figure out if
it's going to work.
You work with the
CFO to convince them
that not having capex
is a good thing.
Because all of the
sudden, your COGS
go up because it's all variable.
And so you have to
have that discussion.
On a cash flow basis,
it might be fantastic.
But from an EBITDA point
of view, it may not be.
So you have to have
all those discussions,
model it, and
actually negotiate.
So we did a whole series of POCs
with the three usual suspects
in terms of our front
end, which is, as I said,
running the auction.
So we took four or five
of our major components
and ran them in all
the public clouds.
And then peered
directly with our colos
for all the other services,
for the 150 other services
that we use.
And ran real production
loads against it,
changing up sizes and figuring
out how we would potentially
scale stuff.
And there's some relatively
meaningless graphs up there.
Don't read anything into it.
But we actually
performance checked it.
Ran it up to around
1,000 QPS just
to see how the
different profiles work.
On the back, our
hourly ETL process,
which is really this enormous
set of MapReduce jobs
with some Spark stuff in there.
We took that and said,
OK, here's an hour,
here's two hours, here's three
hours of raw transaction data.
Let's see how much we can scale
things like EMR or Dataproc
to see if we can actually
do that workload in less
than an hour.
So these were the
two major components.
Can we run an auction and can
we actually process the data?
So what have we
discovered about GCP?
Well, the network latency in GCP
in general is just outstanding.
To everyone in the programmatic
ecosystem, to Google,
of course.
And why should anyone
find that surprising?
If you're in
programmatic advertising,
is it in your interest
to be peered very, very
well with Google and GCP?
Of course.
So if you're in
that infrastructure,
your latency is fantastic.
You get pretty good bang
for the buck on the VMs.
And we could do this across
the different cloud platforms
to figure out, for a
given workload, what
do we need to do.
The other thing
is, remember I said
we're doing this
periodic hourly thing,
where I might need 30,000 to
50,000 cores to do something.
Well, you know, if it
takes somebody two weeks
to try to get that test
to run, that kind of
is an indication they don't have
enough resources to actually
run the business.
So that was a availability
of large resources.
And frankly, the
open source support
with things like Kubernetes,
it's just it's undeniable.
So that's kind of why
we chose Google Cloud.
Thank you.
ANNEKA GUPTA: Well, thank you
for joining for the session.
We at LiveRamp ramp had a
very similar story to OpenX
in terms of the process
that we went through
in looking at Cloud
solutions, the decision
to move to the cloud, and
our decision to use Google.
So LiveRamp's business,
the way we operate,
we're really this data
and identity foundation
for marketers.
You heard Andrea
talk about the fact
that today marketers are
focused on how do they
build incredible
customer experiences.
And, in order to
do that, they need
to be able to harness
all of their data
across all of the
interactions that they're
having with their customers
and be able to leverage
that data to make
better decisions
and interact with our customers
in more meaningful ways.
So we're a key foundational
middleware layer
that enables brands to bring
together all of the data
that they know about
their customers,
segment it, create
audiences, and then
activate it across
any range of ad tech
and martech technologies.
So to give you some history
about where LiveRamp came from.
All of our technology was
in a single colo facility
based in San Francisco.
We have about 100 petabytes
of servers in our colocation
facility.
And we were hitting this point
where we were scaling really,
really quickly as a business.
We needed to be able to
expand to new markets,
expand our products
more quickly,
launch new products
faster, and just continue
to innovate and grow.
Because we're in a
very high growth phase.
And we were hitting
limitations with the fact
that we had all of our data
and all of our services
within a one colocation
facility, which was
getting difficult to manage.
And we weren't able to order
servers fast enough in order
to keep up with our growth.
So we recognized
a couple of years
ago that we actually really
needed to move to the cloud.
And then we went through a very
rigorous process of looking
at what are the different
solutions out there,
what do we think our
needs are, and do
we want to go with
a hybrid solution,
do we want to go
all in on the cloud.
And essentially, it came down
two decision-making factors.
One was looking at what was
the technology available.
And then one was
looking at what are
the costs associated with that.
And we did a pretty
extensive model,
where we were looking
very specifically
at the kinds of
technologies that we would
use within each cloud provider.
How much scale we
would need for that.
Modeling what we
thought the price
was going to be based on
our various conversations
with different cloud providers.
Evaluating the
technologies for the scale
that we are operating at.
And while we have
many similarities
in terms of the scale we're
operating at to OpenX,
we have key differences.
We're not doing a lot
of real-time networking.
We don't have the same kind
of real-time networking
challenges.
We're doing a lot of
big data processing
on huge amounts of amounts
of data that were coming in.
So the way our
product works is we
work with hundreds of brands,
take all of their data,
are processing that
data, and activating it
across hundreds of
platforms, bringing data
back in from those platforms,
and giving that back
to the brand or putting that
into different measurement
solutions.
So we're processing
just tons and tons
of data every single day.
And so a lot of the
challenges that we have
are fairly different than
a lot of other companies
that are storing a lot of data
and processing a lot of data.
For instance, when we thought
about moving to the cloud,
one of the challenges
we had is we're
basically a data
processing company,
so we don't have a lot of
data that's in cold storage.
We have a lot of
data that is live
and it's moving
through a pipeline.
And so when we're
migrating, we're
thinking about what is
this going to look like.
We have to think about
how do we do this
without disrupting our clients.
And so there are a
lot of challenges
that we had to go through in
thinking through this process.
The key thing that we
were thinking about
is, how do we
expand our business?
How do we continue to grow?
And a key part of
what we're focused on
is we're a company
all about helping
people activate their data.
We have 550 integrations
today across a broad range
of categories.
And for us, we have
to think about,
how do we build these
integrations faster?
How do we improve the way
we're pushing and pulling
data from all of these
different ecosystem players?
And how do we just continue to
offer more and more use cases
to our clients.
So all of this was part
of our thought process
as were thinking about
moving to the cloud
and being able to offer
products and innovate faster.
As we also looked at what are
the growth factors for us.
There are a lot
of growth factors.
Again, we're a very
high growth company.
Some of the ones that I
wanted to point out here
is international expansion.
We really needed the ability
to expand internationally
as quickly as possible.
And with all of the data privacy
regulation coming into effect,
we had to think about, how do
we have more data available just
in region?
How do we create the right
permissions around it?
Other parts of our
growth are really
focused around data sharing.
So our Data Store
product enables companies
to monetize their products.
Our second party data
products enabled brands
to share the data with
each other in secure data
partnerships.
And these are products that we
had to think about, how are we
going to build, how are we going
to create the right permissions
around this?
And all of this
factored into the way
we thought about picking
our cloud provider.
So why did we end
up choosing Google?
There are many reasons at play.
As I talked about, it was both
a technology decision and a cost
decision.
And when we started
doing the evaluation
on the technology itself
and we thought about,
hey, what's most important to
our clients, what it came down
to was security.
When we're talking
about data partnerships,
we're taking into our
system valuable data
from a very broad
swath of the ecosystem.
And people expect that
data to be protected.
They expect that
data to be safe.
And we evaluated the
security practices.
And we have very rigorous
security practices
for ourselves in our
colocation facility.
We had to think
about, how are we
going to port that
over to the cloud?
And we were really
impressed by the security
that Google had in place.
And we've actually been
able to up the game in terms
of our security
practices and unlock
a whole new set of use
cases for us, especially
as we get into more
regulated industries
and are opening up new use
cases by working with Google.
The second thing for us is that
we have evolved very quickly,
but we are still a
10-year-old company.
So we had to do an immense
amount of infrastructure
modernization.
And we went through
a big process,
even before we started
migrating, of containerizing
all of our code.
One of the things
that we've really
appreciated in
partnering with Google
is that they've been
able to provide us
professional services and other
advisory around how to actually
migrate our systems to the
cloud, which has actually
sped up the process for us.
So we signed our GCP agreement
in July of last year.
We are hoping to
be on track to be
fully migrated by the
end of August this year.
So we've gone through
a pretty fast process
and we've had lots
of different pieces
that we've had to migrate.
We have our core
systems here in the US.
We have systems internationally
that are slightly different.
And so we've had many
different environments
that we've had to move over.
And as part of that,
really thought about,
how do we modernize
our infrastructure?
The other thing that's
really important to us
is, like I said, we're a
big data processing company.
So looking at the tools that
are available within Google
and recognizing that we
can be part of the road
map of developing those tools
to better suit our business
was a critical component.
And underlying all
of that, there's
the people that we worked with.
When you're entering into a
relationship of this size,
and this is a substantial
investment for us financially,
it's going to help us
improve our gross margins.
We're thinking about how does
this improve our partnership
opportunities.
This is very, very
fundamental to our business.
And so we were looking for
someone we could really partner
with and someone who
would lean in with us
and really help us
innovate faster.
And know that if
we had an issue,
we could pick up the phone
and call someone and get help
for what we needed to.
And honestly, throughout
this migration process
that we've been
through, it keeps
getting reinforced that
the people that we're
working with at Google
are just amazing.
And the technical
expertise they're
able to bring to the table and
bring to our engineering team
has helped us migrate
really quickly.
And I think it bodes
really well for the future
as we continue to
think about innovation.
The last part that I
think is really important,
and Paul mentioned this as
well, is our overall partnership
with Google.
For us, we've had a very
long standing relationship
with the ad side of
the Google business.
And we connect tons of data
into AdWords, into DoubleClick,
and into some of
the newer products
within the Google
Ads stack as well.
And, as we were
thinking about who
do we want to partner with
for the future, for us
it was an obvious decision
to partner with Google.
Because it brings us closer
to the Google's business,
but also because we see so many
of our customers and partners
adopting solutions
on top of Google.
And when we're talking
about integrating data,
if we're all integrated on top
of the same technology stack,
it makes that integration
so much easier.
It makes the data
flow so much faster.
And these are all
things that we're
considering as we're
looking to the future
and making sure that we have
a partner who's really going
to help us grow the business.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I'd like to introduce
Michael from Urban Airship.
MIKE HERRICK: Hi.
Yes, I'm Mike Herrick.
I run technology
for Urban Airship.
And we're a little bit
ahead of these two companies
in terms of our journey.
Ours started three years
ago, at least for me it did.
Three years ago here at Next,
where I met with Google.
We had been evaluating them.
We had previously been 80% in
a colo facility and 20% on AWD.
And so our colo is very quickly
deteriorating underneath us.
We were dealing with failing
hard drives, failing networks.
And it was time to re platform.
And we were considering either
adding a couple of colos
and investing in more hardware
or fully moving to the cloud.
And thankfully, we made a great
choice and moved to Google.
It was a gigantic
undertaking, but we
chose it just given all
the great technology fit.
We used to run a
ton at each base
and each base migrated
really well to Bigtable.
And that was really
important to us.
The migration really went well.
I'll tell you a
bit more about it.
But it really helped
us manage cost.
It's really hard to manage costs
in a colo for a SaaS company.
It really helped us make
our platform more scalable.
I'll show you some
stuff about that.
And more reliable, which really
can't say enough about that
in terms of just the quality
of life of our engineers.
And just the customer
satisfaction that we now enjoy.
And also, now that we're
on the other side of it,
we no longer are
doing crazy things
like balancing Cassandra
rings, and HBase clusters,
and tuning Kafka.
And so our engineers
are able now
to innovate much further up
the stack, which is great.
So just briefly a little
bit about Urban Airship.
Urban Airship is a customer
engagement platform.
So we focus primarily on things
like retention and growth
for our customers.
We help a little bit on
the acquisition side.
But mostly focused
on those two things.
You may know us.
We were the original third
party push notification company,
but we've expanded dramatically
and create many different types
of experiences these days.
We expanded into various
in-app experiences.
We work with Google and Apple
on things like Google Pay,
so mobile wallets.
We power a lot of your
boarding passes, probably,
if you flew some of the
airlines that we support.
We do things on the web,
email, SMS, some other channels
as well.
And we operate at a
pretty great scale.
Ad tech is the only thing
that ever makes me feel small.
But we send 90 billion messages
a month across these channels
and regularly exceed
500,000 messages a second.
And our customer base.
We're pretty much
geared for enterprise,
although we have
customers large and small.
And we have 25% of the
Fortune 100 are our customers.
Really briefly, this is
a look at our platform.
We talked a bit about channels.
We support many of them.
We also have this
open channel API
that a number of
our customers use
to reach things like
over the top networks
that they can't reach
through any other way.
And so that's nice technology.
And we've been investing heavily
in our orchestration layer.
So that's all sorts of things
around targeting, segmentation,
automation, and orchestration
across channels.
Optimizing them.
And then all these
experiences that we
help our customers create send
back a lot of first party data
to Urban Airship.
And we help them
make use of that
by providing rich user
profiles, performance analytics
on that data, machine learning,
and AI capabilities, things
like predictive churn,
same time optimization.
And then we have some technology
to stream this data that we
process out to our customers.
Other aspects of their
marketing technology stack.
Things like BI tools.
Some of our customers use it
to send it to ad networks.
That sort of thing.
So a couple examples of
experiences that we provide.
We work across verticals.
So travel, retail,
media, financial.
I mentioned a lot of airlines.
Our point of view is
the best marketing
isn't really marketing at all.
It's these useful
types of experiences,
where you can provide value and
experiences that users value.
So in travel, things like, hey,
your seat has been upgraded.
In retail, your
package has shipped.
In media, a story that you're
interested in because you're
following a journalist.
Financially, here's
your account balance.
So we do all sorts
of things like that.
Most recently, just last
night, I put this in there
because it was timely.
The NCA is a customer.
And so we've powered all of
their March Madness messaging.
So they do a great job with
anything from score alerts,
to sending videos through
rich notifications,
to even last night after the
game, that kind of famous one
shining moment
video was sent out.
So we were busy last night.
Another quick story.
So last year for
the World Cup, soon
after we finished our
migration to Google Cloud,
we had a bunch of customers
that were really excited
about the World Cup.
Particular one
football really wanted
to make sure that their
notifications arrived
as quickly as possible.
So we worked closely with
them on some technology
that we call Boost.
And this is just a graph.
This was the end of the
World Cup last year.
And we were sending
400,000 notifications
a second for minutes.
That's across our customer base.
We power tons of
media and sports apps.
Since then, we've
exceeded this milestone
and regularly exceed 500,000
notifications a second.
But just to lift
the hood up a bit.
I won't delve into
too much detail.
But this is a look at
one of our subsystems.
We call it the CDP, the
Core Delivery Platform.
So the scale that
we operate means
that we have to
do a lot of things
that maybe we wish
we wouldn't have
to in terms of microservices
and really kind of breaking
some of these components apart.
So we have what we call
a distributed query
planner, which deals with
a lot of these subsystems.
And it leverages a bunch
of Google technology,
like Bigtable.
We leverage a ton of
Cloud Pub/Sub and also
Compute Engine.
But by leveraging
Google technology,
again, compared
back to our colo,
we were able to easily add
capacity for the World Cup.
We can scale it up and down.
And we also were
able to leverage
some of our own innovation
by doing a bunch of software
optimization, doing a lot
of parallel processing,
some advanced queuing of some
of these priority requests.
And so by doing that, we
were able to really meet
our customers' needs.
I think if we hadn't completed
our move to Google Cloud,
just because the World Cup
was so big for our business,
it probably wouldn't
have gone nearly as well.
So that was great.
So I mentioned that we started
our journey 80% on colo,
20% on Amazon.
We're expanding our
footprint more globally now.
So we're moving into
additional regions.
And so it just made sense
for us to consolidate.
We've had somewhat
success with Google.
Our engineers really love it.
And so we've just
collapsed the stack.
This is one of the
projects that our team
is working on right now.
We have business
intelligence capabilities.
So it's really fine
grained user-level data
at the event level.
So just tons and tons of data.
And it's currently
running on Redshift
and has been for
a couple of years.
And that's worked OK.
But our customers
love this product.
They want to see
better performance.
They want fresher data.
And so Bigtable and
BigQuery are really
helping us deliver on
that for our customers.
And so currently we're
loading this data daily
just because it's so much.
And just given some of the
economics that at least
we experience with Redshift.
But we're going to
be able to move that
to minutes instead of per day.
So our customers, as they've
been hearing about this news,
are pretty excited.
And also our storage is
now separated from compute.
If you know anything
about Redshift,
this will make sense to you.
So we can say goodbye to nodes
in reserved instances, which
is great for our cost.
And next, just from a
complexity standpoin--
some of this is just the
way we built the system.
We're doing a lot of software
updates to this as well.
But with this new
version of the system,
we're moving from
some complicated ETL
that we kind of crafted from
canisius and microservices
to one single dataflow job.
So just really dramatically
simplifies the system.
And then just our maintenance
overhead is reduced.
We now have to deal
with vacuums anymore,
which has been
less than awesome.
And then BigQuery
cluster tables really
enable efficient queries.
And for some of the queries,
given the complexity of data,
have to do with a lot of
scanning of the entire data
set, which is really slow.
So that's great.
And then, as we
look to the future,
we have big aspirations
for our company
and creating more and more
capabilities in our customer
engagement platform.
And so we're seeking to leverage
more and more of Google Cloud.
Right now all of our machine
learning capabilities
are built in-house.
And we're experimenting
with leveraging
some of the Google's stuff.
Our job is to innovate
further up the stack
and not bother with
things like managing
each base in hard drives.
So anyways, that's my story.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]